j'ai que diverses
c'est quand même la seule émission au
monde où ils rendraient de luxe man et
dick rivers côte à côte
bah oui je sais pas si vous avez fait à
vos cheveux il y en a ils sont tous
blancs vous ils sont tous noirs
oui c'est marrant ça bah oui mais il
pourrait avoir des cheveux un peu plus
noir aussi six mois si vous voulez mais
c'est ce qu'on lui dit toujours mais il
veut pas mais ça lui va très bien ça lui
va bien
c'est son look ouais rien de formidable
vous êtes plutôt années 50 comme
coiffure et le fuseau années 60 voile
voilà absolument années 2000 bien alors
dit que les versions soir bonsoir
dick rivers je dis à mes amis des
spectateurs c'est à dire la [ __ ] des
rivières alors oui bah oui dis que c'est
la dite rivers bas c'est à dire j'ai je
vais vous dire une chose si quand j'ai
commencé à chanter quand j'ai choisi ce
nom quand j'avais 15 ans ouais si on
m'avait dit que ça voulait dire ça
j'aurais appris ce prénom d'avant donc
je veux dire à mots nazis c'est quelque
chose qui est venu beaucoup plus tard
ouais c'est une sorte de popol voilà
génial génial allenby toujours la banane
voilà ça fait plaisir alain après un
moment en fait vous appeler comme ça à
cause d'un personnage interprété par
elvis presley dans loving you exactement
à l'assise appelé dick d eux qu à eux et
ils se prononcent dic mais on a lancé ça
aurait fait des quais ou doc
mais la [ __ ] seddik des lycées cas comme
vous voilà mais je répète c'est popol
les dinos mignon en tout cas vous êtes
un personnage arrêt votre personnage a
complètement bouffé finalement ce que
vous êtes
on croit que vous dormez dans un jukebox
que que ce que j'écris en voiture
amérique voilà que vous nourrissez
uniquement de hamburgers et ça c'est
vrai oui les gens s'imaginent ça alors
que vous avez une smart et vous vivez à
toulouse je ne vis pas tout je vis à
paris mais j'ai une maison à côté de
tout noualhat ouais alors par exemple on
croit toujours d'être pote avec géniale
idée dit mitchell
vous avez trois inséparables on se
connaît visitez dit
j'ai toujours une guéguerre entre les 2
m
depuis 40 ans ballet à l'époque des
chats sauvages des choses et je vous
recommande iam non il ya presque ça dure
quand même dit il vieillit et comme s'il
était le seul et johnny vous dites c'est
devenu un 14 juillet non je disais que
ces spectacles sont absolument
faramineux quoi adresse et c'est un
petit peu comme les rolling stones c'est
à dire les rolling stones maintenant
c'est quand même le plus grand groupe de
rock encore assistant mais jure les
spectacles des stands c'est quand même
on y va avant tout pour le spectacle je
pense que jojo ses pareils manquez pas
d'air quand même à vous avez déclaré
dans françois en 2005 pour les uns je
suis culte pour les autres je suis
branché
oui il ya un autre tiers que tu as
oublié mais c'est pas ça c'est que je
touche à peu près plus de deux
générations dont la rue il ya chacun
sait qu'un simple juge
voyez ce que je veux vous et a pu
tellement longtemps que je me dis soit
culte soient branchés voilà pour
certains c'est la pad au trip la légende
et puis pour d'autres c'est branché
parce que on est toujours branché pour
quelqu un vrai on est toujours le
branché de quelques sûrement sûrement
alors pourtant quand même c'est pas si
simple parce que vous dites drucker se
passe pas bien à quoi dhr qui arrive
vous ignorent ça se passe pas bien
michel oui c'est un faux gentil m'invite
jamais j'ai jamais regardé une émission
de michel le dimanche et lui
batum a ignoré disons depuis 300 et 1000
depuis qui fait l'après midi avant je
faisais à l'époque de champs elysées
j'ai fait des émissions est pourquoi je
vous invite pas je sais pas arrêter tu
as oublié faire ce qu'il dit tu es trop
branché pour brücker salazie
didier